i always say that to when i met bro like
he taught me a lot of [ __ ] that
i was like damn i told him like well i
just needed an older brother right right
right around me and what we had going on
already we [ __ ] around being
some of the biggest rappers in north
carolina six years ago told [ __ ] but
i wasn't rapping there we were just
doing a lot of [ __ ] living like roberts
2 and like
like when i met baby he was like um
like yeah man i seen y'all look at them
vlogs and [ __ ] right
because originally forensic trucks and
[ __ ] you originally like got him for one
of your records i guess yeah
yeah and he just respected the way you
moved and the way you were doing things
so much that he was like yo let's work
right yeah it was just like let's work
first it wasn't anything i'm assigned it
was less work but baby so
like about his business it probably was
i'm gonna sign you first from the jump
but he was like it was also like he was
trying to figure me out yeah he was
trying to
like i know like you feel me like trying
to get to know me trying to make sure
like we can do this and do business
first cause we probably hung out like
probably a month straight first for sure
before i just signed